perché sur les rives du bosphore
istanbul est devenue la cité d'accueil
des parias de russie c'est le cas de
nick guina journaliste indépendante à
moscou elle a fui la répression qui
s'abat sur la presse depuis le début de
la guerre
c'était probablement la décision la plus
difficile de ma vie elle a été prise
rapidement mais je ne savais pas pour
combien de temps j'allais partir alors
j'ai fait une valise j'ai pris ma caméra
et je suis parti
depuis la loi votée au parlement russe
sur les fausses informations qui prévoit
de fortes peines de prison au moins 150
journalistes sont partis une vingtaine
se trouvait à istanbul où les russes
n'ont pas besoin de visa pour venir nous
ne sommes pas des traîtres nous aimons
la russie et nous voulons rentrer chez
nous c'est notre maison pas celle de
poutine
ni guina poursuit son travail à istanbul
ce matin elle filme d'autres exilés
russes comme macha responsable d'un
théâtre à saint pétersbourg cet
activiste anti guerre a toujours son
compagnon bloqué en russie
j'ai vraiment peur pour lui parce qu'il
pourrait être envoyé à l'armée mais pour
l'instant il est encore à l'abri vous
voyez on a le choix c'est la prison où
l'armée
parfois ce sont des familles entières
qui débarque à istanbul
logée par une amie turc vlad et maria
viennent d'arriver le couple de
cinéastes et très engagé contre la
politique de poutine il aurait pu être
arrêtés à la frontière
j'ai nettoyé mon ordinateur parce que je
produis des films politiques des
documentaires contre le régime donc ces
dossiers je les ai enlevés oui j'avais
peur
mais à istanbul la famille a repris son
combat
non à la guerre ne touchez pas à
l'ukraine en russie ces manifestations
sont interdites
en russie je ne serai pas libres
actuellement je n'aurai aucune chance
même petit de me faire entendre
ils semblent n'est qu'un point de
passage une halte dans la quête d'une
vie meilleure loin du régime répressif
de vladimir poutine s'est réfugié russe
désormais souhaite rejoindre l'europe
pour se mettre un temps à l'abri